hey this is crushed all walker weather
in math land is determined by chance if
it rains on a given day then the
probability it will rain
the next day increases by 10 percentage
points up to 100 percent if it does not
rain on a given day then the probability
it will rain on the next day decreases
by 10 percentage points down to zero
percent if the probability it will rain
today is 60 percent what is the
probability that it will eventually rain
every day for all time can you figure it
out
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll set up the problem by writing P
sub X to mean the probability it rained
forever from a day with an X percent
chance of rain when the probability of
rain reaches 100 percent it will rain
forever and when the probability of rain
reaches 0% it never rains again
according to our notation this means P
sub 100 is equal to 1 and P sub 0 is
equal to 0 we're interested in the
intermediate probabilities which will
depend on the probabilities of these
other states for example if the
probability rains on a given day is 90%
we will either transition with 90% to
the probability state where we have a
hundred percent chance of rain or we
will transition with the 10% chance to
the probability state of an 80 percent
chance of rain
similarly suppose there is an 80 percent
chance that you're going to rain on the
given day there's going to be an 80
percent chance you're going to increase
by 10% to the 90% state and there's
going to be a 20 percent chance they're
going to decrease to the state of having
70 percent chance the next day we can
similarly compute these probabilities
for all the other states each day you're
going to transition either up 10% or
down 10% depending on the current day's
probability of rain we now have a system
of equation and we can solve this
systematically we start from the very
last equation we have T sub 0 is equal
to 0 which we then substitute in to the
next equation we then get peace of 10 in
terms of peace of 20 well then use this
information and substitute in to the
next equation we can solely climb up
this ladder of equation
and get each state in terms of the
probability of another state now where
does this platter end well when we get
to the top we have P sub 90 is equal to
five eleven over five twelve times P sub
100 now we know the piece of 100 is
equal to one so we know that this is
equal to five eleven over five twelve we
now climb back down the ladder of this
these sets of equations we can
substitute in the probability P sub 90
into the previous state piece of 80 and
we'll keep climbing down until we get to
piece of sixty and this will be one
ninety one over 256 which is
approximately a seventy four point six
percent chance that it will rain forever
and this is the answer to our problem
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch one of our
blogs mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
Parker and if you like video please
check out my book there are links in the
video description